what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Sony's spider-verse seems to be
taking some really cool directions that
I think fans are really going to enjoy
Sony is expanding their spider verse
Universe which is going to be a big
connected Universe much like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but of course this is
going to be secluded to Spider-Man
characters and now we have an
announcement for the next installation
for the Sony spider-verse franchise and
it's pretty dang cool announced today by
the time this video gets out it would
probably have been announced for an hour
now Donald Glover is going to start in
and produce a Spider-Man villain movie
about the character Hypno Hustler Hypno
Hustler is a very interesting and kind
of out there character but we'll break
the character down talk about this
upcoming movie and talk about Sony's
plans for the spider-verse because right
now they're actually looking really good
and the spider verse is getting more
exciting as time goes by it seemed like
they didn't really have a plan before
but but now it's looking like everything
is well underway with the new plan that
they have also reminder about our
giveaway we're giving away an item from
the Marvel Legends series all you got to
do to enter is subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment on each of our
videos we'll pick a random comment for
the winner and the winner will be
announced in videos so please don't fall
for any of the scams out there if you
have won it will be announced in a video
so at this point in time I think a lot
of people know Donald Glover he's been
in many movies at this point he played
Lando in Solo a Star Wars story he also
played Troy Barnes in community which is
an amazing series and of course not to
mention he is also the Childish Gambino
many people know who that is he sings
the very popular song this is America
and I also suggest checking out
sweatpants that's a really great one as
well today this is coming from The
Hollywood Reporter the title of the
article reads as I stated Donald Glover
to start in produce Spider-Man movie
based on villain Hypno Hustler it then
goes on to say glubber is attached to
Star and produce a feature set in so
Sony's Spider-Man universe of the Marvel
Comics characters so make no mistake
this is set in the same universe that
venomous set in that morbius is set in
and that Madame web is set in and we'll
get into what this means for the entire
universe and how Sony actually has a
good plan in just a bit but let's first
talk about how miles Murphy the son of
actor and comedian Eddie Murphy is
already on board with the project to
write it it has no title right now but
as The Hollywood Reporter stated it's to
revolve around Hypno Hustler one of the
more obscure Spider-Man villains now
let's address kind of the elephant in
the room yes Donald Glover was in
Spider-Man homecoming so technically
Donald Glover he does exist in the MCU
as Prowler the uncle of Miles Morales
and this really does make you wonder if
there is any plan to kind of continue
that story with him being Prowler in the
MCU I'm saying no after we get this
announcement I'm pretty sure Miles
Morales is going to make his way to the
MCU at some point in time most likely
after Tom Holland Spider-Man is done
probably within the next three to five
years however it probably won't be based
off of Prowler being his uncle or if it
is they probably won't ever mention it
again or if they do happen to mention
again Donald Glover probably won't be
shown because they don't want to mix the
two universes especially since he's
playing a completely different character
now I am really excited for this because
this character I think is absolutely
perfect for Donald Glover to play he's
probably not a very well-known character
but he was created by Bill mantlow the
writer who also created Rocket Raccoon
and also created by the artist Frank
Springer and he's very heavily
influenced by the Disco era as The
Hollywood Reporter States this was the
product of the disco music scene when he
first appeared in Peter Parker The
Spectacular Spider-Man number 24 in
1978. his real name was Antoine the Sun
the leader of a band called The Mercy
killers and he uses hypnosis technology
in his instruments on his audience in
order to Rob them now if you are a fan
of Donald Glover slash the Childish
Gambino and if you you've seen Community
all the way through you could probably
picture how Donald Glover is perfect for
this character in fact when I hear that
he is playing Hypno Hustler I think of
one particular scene here
Santa invented Spielberg and my bro
chips Santa invented Coca-Cola
code granted he is a lot older now but
his acting skills have improved vastly
as well not to say he wasn't great in
community because he absolutely was but
I think this is an incredible project
for Donald Glover and I think this is
actually a really good direction that
Sony is taking and it says a lot about
their future plans for their
spider-verse in fact I think this is an
extremely important move and I'll
explain in just a bit but first big
thank you to Mint mobile for sponsoring
this video most people know about mint
mobile because of Ryan Reynolds but most
people don't know about mint Mobile's
amazing quality now I live in the
mountains and service isn't too good
however mint mobile sent me a free plan
and I get better service with their plan
than I do with my other provider but
what's crazy is their plan is so much
cheaper mint mobile offers Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month they give you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and at mint mobile families
start at only two lines all plans come
with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5 G network plus mint
Mobile's Modern Family Plan lets you mix
and match data plans so everyone gets
the amount of data that's right for them
and you can use your own phone and keep
your same number and contacts so to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month including the Modern Family Plan
go to mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now something that
I think needs to be addressed is how
important this movie actually is for the
Sony spider verse I've already seen a
ton of comments online stating that Sony
sucks he's supposed to be Prowler we're
supposed to get Miles Morales and I
totally and absolutely get that however
Spider-Man homecoming was in 2017 almost
six years ago and as we know their plans
have definitely changed over the course
of these five almost six years and like
I mentioned before I think they're going
to go a different route with Miles
Morales in the MCU but also at the same
time I do think this is a good idea for
Sony because they're doing something
thing that hasn't really been done much
before they are telling the stories of
not only Heroes but also villains where
getting the Crave in the hunter movie
and the test screenings have already
come out for that and people say that
it's actually pretty good plus we have
had a ton of superhero movies all
focused really on Heroes over the past
decade and then some actually over two
decades now and there hasn't really been
much focus on villains of course the
focus on the villains is in other
superhero movies also about Heroes Loki
was really the first series that we got
that was focused on a villain and even
then he kind of didn't really become the
villain by the end he was kind of a hero
and I love Loki and I'm not bashing it
by any means but I do like the idea of
diving into villains stories and this
makes Sony's spider-verse different than
what we've really got before and this
really does open up its potential now
they are starting their own Multiverse
in The spider-verse Madam Webb is
supposed to introduce it and this is
really great and I feel like Sony really
is heading in the right direction they
are making a spider-verse where they
they can connect a bunch of different
Spider-Man characters but not only just
different variants of Spider-Man but
other characters including villains and
there are a ton of Spider-Man villains
that I would love to get their own
project whether that be a show or a
movie just imagine if we got a movie on
black cat a movie completely about
Kingpin or completely about Dr Octopus
or Norman Osborne I personally think
that fans would really really enjoy
these movies and it would be very very
refreshing and I think that's what Sony
is on to right now they're creating a
spider-verse that isn't just focused on
Spider-Man but it's focused on everyone
around Spider-Man from the comics
including villains I personally think
that this is an extremely good idea and
this actually kind of makes me more
excited for the Sony spider-verse but
hey let me know what you think about all
this in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
relating to the spider-verse for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching wolf wolf